it took me forever but I finally figured
out what this newspaper says and what
implications it has for the story stick
around at the end of this video if you
want to see it in 2017 I made one of the
first movie things you missed episodes
on its chapter 1 here's what I said at
the end and when the trailer for chapter
2 drops you can count on the things you
missed episode from me and today that
trailer did drop so here's me keeping my
promise just as the losers Club keeps
their promise to return to Derry should
it rise again the trailer begins with
Beverly going back to her father's old
apartment she hasn't talked to him since
moving the Chicago years ago and it
would probably be a bit awkward
considering she smashed his head open
the last time they saw each other in
1989 when she arrives she discovers that
her father is no longer there instead
there's this old woman named mrs. Kirsch
Beverly thinks that she may have misread
the name on the door somehow confusing
her own last name Marsh with Kirsch but
in the opening shot of the trailer it
clearly says Marsh that finds the
postcard given to her by Ben 27 years
ago while mrs. Kirsch is making tea and
if you pay attention to Beverly's arms
they're covered in bruises in the novel
that has an abusive husband too named
Tom who she flees from to come to Derry
she also has something hanging around
her neck I'm not sure what it is but it
reminds me of the key that she wore as a
child we never see what it's for in the
first movie mrs. Curtis shirt is covered
in birds and birds can be seen
throughout her apartment which could be
clue about her true nature it's not
really mentioned in chapter 1 but birds
play a major part in the novel where
Mike first encounters it's in the form
of a giant bird that attacks him and
Stan would later use his vast knowledge
of birds to determine that it's bird
form is not real which weakens it as
Beverly looks around the apartment at
the photos mrs. Kirsch peeks out and
looks at her all naked and creepy like
that woman from the visit
the photo shows Pennywise in his human
form Bob gray another detail that wasn't
part of the first film before she
attacks mrs. Kirsch asked the following
question what about you are you still
his little girl are you this is probably
a reference to Beverly's fear of her
father and the fact that it takes the
shape of her dad temporarily during the
final battle in Chapter one then we
finally get our reveal shot of some more
members of the losers Club including
Mike Ritchie bill Beverly and bang Eddie
doesn't show up until later in the
trailer they see themselves as kids in
the reflection of this window one of the
many ways they become more childlike
when they return to Derry much like how
bill gets to stutter back in the book
and the scars that they cut into their
hands to make the promise reappear when
they find out that it's bad they're also
in front of an ice cream shop there is a
scene where they get ice cream in the
book after Ben stands up for Beverley
against this kid named Bradley Donovan
hopefully the childhood flashbacks in in
Chapter two were gonna fill in some of
the events that took place that summer
but they didn't have room for in the
first movie as opposed to the flashbacks
just being used to reiterate stuff that
looks to be the case because this shot
of them riding bikes is a completely
different day than anything that happens
in the first one I've never seen Ritchie
wearing this zombie hand shirt before
one such flashback could be hinted at in
this scene of Richie at city centre in
the first one this is where we learned
that Richie is afraid of clowns this
Paul Bunyan statue is shown but it
doesn't do anything in the movie in the
book Ritchie goes there by himself one
day and the statue comes to life and
attacks him so maybe that's a scene that
we'll get to see in a flashback there
are other locations that they return to
from the first movie like the hill
leading to the Barrens and this sewer
pipe when they first meet Ben it looks
like the water is higher now the town is
once again littered with a missing child
posters as it was in 1989 I found it
interesting that it's not the busy town
that it once was the streets are empty
it took me a while to decipher what this
blurry daily Derry newspaper headline
said but I've come to the conclusion
that it says body found in Barrens this
must be Dennis Torrio a boy who's
murdered in the novel and please find a
Georgie's picture at the crime scene
speaking of which it looks like the
ghost of Georgie is not done haunting
bill this Tiny's restaurant is called
the oriental Jay and this is where they
meet up for the first time
in 27 years I noticed that this Gong in
the background here isn't moving and I
can just see Ritchie slamming the dong
to commence their meeting and disturbing
all the other diners ok this shot shows
thousands of balloons under a bridge one
for every comment that tells me that I
look like shaggy no but what this really
is is the event that sets the new cycle
of its into motion it starts at a
festival celebrating dairy I'm guessing
that's what this is three drunk guys
come to harass a gay couple and one of
them gets pushed off of a bridge well
penny wise is waiting and bites the
guy's arm off before thousands of read I
love dairy balloons rise up hit the
bottom of the bridge for this shot I'm
not gonna go into it because I don't
want some viewer to get mad about
spoilers and then come to my house and
bite my ear off or something but if you
want a clue I'll just say read chapter
21 in the book I think that's what we're
saying here I will however talk about
this other shot where we see the white
clown gloves grabbing this little ball
of light when I talked about the first
movie i theorize that these little
lights that Beverly sees down the throat
of it are an interpretation of the dead
lights the true form of its and I think
that's what we're seeing again here
Pennywise using the dead lights to
hypnotize this girl the little girl with
the bruise on her face can be seen
wandering under the bleachers during
some kind of sporting event my guess is
this is dawn Roy a 13 year old girl
found dead in McCarren Park Mike tells
everyone about the recent pattern of
dead or missing children at the lunch at
the Chinese restaurant and this is one
of the victims that he mentions if you
need a refresher on some of the things
that you missed from the first movie
click the video on the left I'm planning
a whole slate of videos about it chapter
2 from now until the movie is released
in September so make sure you subscribe
to seize these worlds for new Horrors
every week bring that death belt for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we all float
[Music]